[Musique]
très bien nous allons nous connecter
wifi du coup avoue fils ça veut dire
allons-y et nous sommes en ligne
[Musique]
cool
content juste une petite question
kwal internet regarde moi tous ces
machins
félicitations vous d'été gros gagnant
ses six enfants stars ont fait de la
prison le numéro 6 est favori je suis
très intéressant
bienvenue sur hiver mesdames et
messieurs voici le lot suivant une toile
sur velours noir d'un chaton dépressif
j'ai l'impression qu'il me regarde avec
ses juges j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas
que ces yeux qui te regarde
[Musique]
on va jouer au poker avec le chèque
je comprends maintenant pourquoi tout le
monde adore ce jeu là ça détend encore
plus sévère le mouvement bonjour je
voudrais continuer ainsi choisi non le
petit chat y mange les milkshakes le
lapin lui y mange les femmes kate
les